How far would you go for love?
If you’re a Western Grey Whale you might
go a whooping 14,000 miles!
Hey everyone, Julia here for DNews
Many animals migrate.
Birds, fish, reptiles, mammals, all do it.
Lots of animals travel to greener pastures
to mate or feed.
By far and away the most common reasons is
to get the hell away from winter.
Most migrations are to areas of warmer climates
for the winter and back North again for the
summer.
Not unlike your snow bird grandparents, animals
are willing to go pretty far for fairer weather.
A recent study published in the journal of
Biology Letters made quite a splash.
A team of researchers from the US and Russia
tracked a Western Grey Whale for a while.
I mean.
A WHILE.
This whale, Varvara started from Russia's
Sakhalin Island, where their feeding grounds
are and journeyed across the Pacific Ocean,
down the West Coast of the United States all
the way to their breeding grounds off the
coast of Baja, Mexico.The total milage she
racked up?
She swam right into the record books at almost
14,000 miles round trip.
Making it the longest mammal migration ever
recorded!
But she’s not the only one willing to go
the distance.
Caribou, also called reindeer, are found across
the northern regions of North America, Europe
and Asia.
Some herds are really really big.
The Porcupine caribou herd is 169,000 animals
large!
In the spring as the cold arctic tundras thaw,
the caribou journey far northward to feed
on newly exposed grasses and plants.
And as the cold sets back in, they head back
south to chow on lichens.
The journey can take as many as 1,600 miles
each way, making it the longest land migration
for mammals.
No talk about migrations is complete without
mentioning the monarch butterfly.
The Eastern population can fly over 3,000
miles to spend the winter in warmer weather
in Mexico.
Some can fly up to 50 miles a day!
Yet their population is in decline, mostly
due to habitat destruction and changes in
climate.
They use a process called time compensated
sun navigation to find their way.
Basically they use the position of the sun
and the time of day as tools to keep them
going in the right direction throughout their
long trip.
It may come as no surprise but birds fly the
furthest.
The award for the longest bird migration ever
goes to the tiny arctic tern.
It took a little while for scientists to figure
this out.
Previously, the award went to a bigger bird,
the sooty shearwater, who topped out at a
40,000 mile trip.
But as technology allowed for smaller tracking
devices, researchers turned to ever smaller
birds.
The Arctic terns long journey starts in Greenland
and every year, after a little zig-zagging
around, the bird winds up 44,000 miles away
in Antarctica.
Another recent study published in the journal
Biology Letters found one of the longest non-stop
flights for any bird.
The blackpoll warbler flies over 1,500 miles
in one fell swoop.
Over two or three days, the songbird flies
from the forests of New England and Canada
and heads to the Caribbean for the winter.
To prep for the long trip, a bird might pack
on an extra 5 or 6 grams fat.
While bigger birds like the northern wheatear
fly a little further, a researcher from York
University not involved in the study told
Newsweek that “it’s more impressive”
that so small a bird like the blackpoll warbler
can make it so far.
The longest non-stop flight of all however
goes to the Alaskan bar-tailed godwit.
Over eight days, the bird will travel from
Alaska to New Zealand.
An almost 7,000 mile trip with no breaks.
So how do birds travel so far?
How do they know where they’re going?
Well they are some how able to sense the Earth’s
magnetic field.
Some researchers from the University of Oxford
think that a magnetically sensitive protein
called cryptochrome that regulates circadian
rhythms might be responsible.
As blue or green lights hit atoms it makes
electrons spin in response to magnetic fields.
Weird right?